Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard schönen
guten Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich
am altbewährten Ort weißt du eigentlich
stell die Frage eigentlich nur aus
rhetorischen Gründen weißt du dass das
mittlerweile auch der Titel eines
eigenen Podcasts ist ich habe das
munkeln hören wirklich immer Stadelmann
Andreas loff und jetzt pass auf Atze
macht er auch gelegentlich mit ich finde
das schön habe mich sehr darüber gefreut
ja ich glaube die verarschen uns total
aber trotzdem nett ja ich finde es gut
ja ich kann das ja gerne mal anhören
richtig kultig ich bin auf den halben
Sommer über so begrüßt worden
ich habe das Bild gesehen ich habe das
Bild gesehen das geht da gibt's doch so
ein Logo zu das habe ich gesehen gehört
habe ich das nicht aber das Logo von
nicht schön
ne und du hattest deine Polarforscher
Kluft an und das lustige ist dass ich ja
zu Hause sitze und du fragst Richard wo
erreiche ich dich während du dich also
im wilden Grönland rumtreibst richtig
das finde ich gut man darf ja mal
träumen ist doch schön nee aber das war
richtig gut auch schön ge gerechnet das
muss man sagen hat mir gefallen ja und
ich finde du hast auch sowas gurueskes
in letzter Zeit finde ich das mag ich
hast du eigentlich mitgekriegt dass wir
Teil des medialen Sommerlochs waren ja
habe ich so am Rande auch mitgekriegt
und ich ich habe da so ein paar Sachen
mitgekriegt und das hat mich dann
wirklich verwundert also der Tenor zum
Beispiel in Berliner Kurier auch SPIEGEL
ONLINE hat sich über lange Strecke mit
uns beschäftigt und so weiter und der
Tenor war Brecht und Lanz lästern über
junge Leute und der Anlass war ein
Gespräch gar kein Podcast sondern im
Gespräch auf auf im März glaube ich was
in München auf dem handwerkskongress
kann ich mich gut daran erinnern genau
ich mochte das damals sehr weil wir
beide ja Handwerk sehr schätzen und das
war schön mit den Leuten dort zu kommen
und ich muss sagen ich ich war irritiert
über diesen tätowier lässt ihn über
junge Leute und dann kam auch so ein
paar Leute rausgeritten auch hier eben
junge Menschen wir beide haben eine
ganze Folge über die Generation Z
gemacht und haben auch ich selber im
Fernsehen habe so oft gesagt wie gern
ich die habe wie sehr ich die mag ja und
und dann gehen die danach vorne und und
fallen über uns her auf eine Art und
Weise das mochte ich irgendwie nicht und
und der Tenor war immer wieder wir
hätten sozusagen über die gelästert und
hängte sich da so auf an diesem einen
Satz auch von mir und wir sind eine eine
wirklich Gefühle der Gesellschaft
geworden so eine hafermilch-truppe ja
und und und
versprochen
nicht nur für Leute unter 30 sondern wir
sind ja die Gefühle die Gesellschaft
durch und durch geworden alle unter 25
mit eingenommen ja und dachte dann gut
er hat demonstrand um Offenbarung sehr
gefährlich Veranstaltung das war eine
Veranstaltung die Handwerker waren da in
einer
Situation dass sie sich darüber
beklagten dass sie kaum noch Leute
kriegen das natürlich auch gerade in der
jüngeren Generation immer weniger Leute
das Handwerk erlernen wollen und dass
die Arbeitsbedingungen im Handwerk
natürlich auch häufig so sind wie viele
jüngere Leute sie sich nicht wünschen so
und dann haben wir darauf reagiert und
haben zunächst mal den Befund untersucht
ne den haben gesagt das ist so die
Ansprüche der Generation heute sind
nicht mehr die gleichen Ansprüche der
Generation die wir hatten und schon gar
nicht die die unsere Eltern oder
Großeltern hatten sondern das ist in der
Tat so dass man heute von seiner
Arbeitswelt weit weniger Zumutungen
erwartet als man früher für
selbstverständlich in Kauf nehmen musste
ob man wollte oder nicht richtig wird
und dass man sehr viel aufnehmen ich bin
froh dass mein Kindern das erspart
bleibt genau also die Art von Ausbeutung
die ich zum Beispiel erlebt habe die die
möchte ich keinem einzige meiner Kinder
jemals irgendwie angegangen werden
also ich bin Jahrgang 64 ist ja der
geboten stärkste Übergang der
Bundesrepublik also in keiner Generation
gab es so viele Kinder wie also 64 war
der absolute Höhepunkt war ja noch vor
dem Pillenknick und da wir so viele
waren konnten sich die Arbeitgeber die
Leute aussuchen selbst wenn jetzt im
Ferienjob oder sowas gemacht hat das ja
und bei so viele das machten und so
viele darauf drängen konnte man auch
schlecht bezahlen und so weiter und so
weiter so und ich habe ihn jetzt nicht
hingegangen und habe gesagt ja das waren
die guten alten Zeiten sondern ich habe
gesagt jede Zeit produziert die Menschen
die zu dieser Zeit passen wenn du dir
diese Ansprüche stellen kannst heute
dann stellst du sie und wir haben sie
damals nicht gestellt weil wir sie nicht
stellen konnten und diesen Prozess habe
ich geschrieben habe ich gesagt für
unsere Eltern und Großeltern war das
Leben eben kein Wunschkonzert heute ist
es sehr viel mehr Wunschkonzert nicht
für alle aber für viele und hast du
diesen ganzen Prozess geschrieben und
dann darf ich in der Presse lesen ich
hätte sozusagen die gute alte Zeit
gefeiert ja das haben wir halt eben
nicht natürlich du weißt ja nee ich
stehe ja manchmal mit dem Journalismus
auf Kriegsfuß wenn man sowas hilft und
man schreibt dann auch noch in ganz
langen Artikel auf Spiegel Online und
mit den gesamten Zusammenhang der
Geschichte nicht mal recherchiert sich
nicht mal das ganze Gespräch angehört
und sich dann ein Urteil
zusammenschreiben ich meine das erfüllt
ja nicht mal die Allerkleinsten
Mindeststandards und Journalismus wo man
sich ja erstmal gucken muss worüber
haben die da geredet in welchem Kontext
wie war das ganze Gespräch es gibt ja
glaube ich jemand auf Youtube der hat
sich die Mühe mal gemacht dass alles
meine Ruhe aufzuarbeiten habe ich mir
angesehen Marvin Neumann liebe Grüße an
der Stelle übrigens auch an Ärzte habe
ich von ganz vergessen Marvin neumann
hat sich das alles mal angesehen und hat
es auseinander genommen und ist auch
kritisch mit uns umgegangen so wie es
sein muss aber der kam zu einem ganz
anderen Befund das hat mir gut gefallen
das andere war zum Teil aus der
Abteilung zu viele Recherche macht die
schöne Geschichte dann auch kaputt ja
weil für unsere Zeit dass wir häufig auf
Youtube
Geschichten finden oder Darstellungen
finden die elaborierter genauer präziser
und ehrlicher sind als das was ich
sogenannte Qualitätsmedien an
Journalisten leisten das muss man mal in
dieser Deutlichkeit sagen gab da noch
ein Gedanken über den ich gestolpert bin
und von dem ich dich
da hat sich fundamental was geändert
Aurel März sagt die möglicherweise was
ist ein junger Comedian schätze ich
interessanter Mann der sie aber
fürchterlich darüber aufgeregt hat und
sich total angegriffen gefühlt hat von
von diesem Satz und offenbar ein großer
Fan von Hafermilch auf jeden Fall hat er
ist ja ganz böse mit mir ins Gericht
gegangen und machte dann am Ende das
darf auch alles ist alles in Ordnung
aber es war sehr polemisch nur am Ende
macht er dann so ein fast auf und sagt
was ist eigentlich gute daran wenn man
ein gutes Leben will so dramatisch und
so ein bisschen metodramatischer also
sehr pathetisch spricht überhaupt nichts
gegen ich habe
ein Buch geschrieben über die
Arbeitsgesellschaft ein 500 seitenbuch
indem ich diesen Wandel von der
klassischen Arbeitsgesellschaft zu
sinngesellschaft wie ich sie nenne
erklär
und um dann angegangen zu werden von
jemandem der keine Zeile davon gelesen
hat und exakt das Gegenteil über uns
sagt von dem was meine Aussage ist und
wozu ich seit Jahren Vorträge Pflege
entzündete sich an dem Wort oder meiner
Kritik sozusagen ich habe ja der Satz
gegen weiter wir sind die ganze Zeit auf
der Suche nach der Work-Life-Balance ja
ja und diese Gegenüberstellung das habe
ich schon mal gesagt ich ich tue mich
damit wahnsinnig schwer also sozusagen
ein gutes Leben ist die Abwesenheit von
Arbeit den Gedanken habe ich nie
verstanden für mich war ein gutes Leben
immer mit sehr viel Arbeit verbunden und
Arbeit hat so oft dafür gesorgt dass das
Leben gut war ja aber du meinst deine
Arbeit eine Arbeit sind genau also
richtig gute Arbeit ja die sind stiftend
ist die bringt dich automatisch in eine
live-balance weil sie nämlich nicht nach
als Ruhe empfunden wird genau sondern
weil sie genauso unmittelbarer
Bestandteil deiner Lebenswelt ist und
der Sache in der du vorkommst und machen
willst und dass dieses Bedürfnis jüngere
Leute danach so groß geworden ist liegt
einfach daran weil eben sehr viel mehr
solche Berufe heute zur Verfügung stehen
und weil deutlich weniger Menschen als
früher harte workarbeit machen müssen
unter Tage arbeiten im stallwerk
arbeiten und irgendwann künftig auch
nicht mehr so viel langweilige
Büroarbeit machen müssen und das ist ja
alles eine Entwicklung die ich absolut
begrüße die ich regelrecht feiere ja
genau so geht es mir auch deswegen ist
da denke ich manchmal man seid doch mal
an ein bisschen ein bisschen genauer und
auch mal ein bisschen nachsichtiger mit
einem alten weißen Mann ja ich habe eine
ganz
spezielles nicht aufgefasst sein ich
habe in meinem Leben ein einziges Mal
Hafermilch getrunken das ist eine wahre
Geschichte und weißt du wo das war
bei dir im Studio
vor unserem letzten Video Podcast
und so viel zum Thema
wahnsinnig künstliches Produkt
also
egal habe ich schon gemacht großartig
aber was ich nur meine ist Richard da
baut sich so ein Konflikt auf so ein
Generation kommt mit man merkt auch da
gibt es eine wahnsinnigen über eine Wut
einen brass auf uns auf diese ja Boomer
ich habe mir das mal angesehen ist total
interessant weißt du wann das das erste
mal so als Schimpfwort benutzt worden
ist nachweislich nee es gibt eine junge
neuseeländische Politikerin
heißt die 25 Jahre alt war sie damals
2019 und hat
eine Rede eines deutlich älteren
parlamentsabgeordnet natürlich ein Mann
zur Schnecke gemacht der der hat sie
immer wieder unterbrochen da reingerufen
und hat hat genervt und sie hat ihn mit
zwei Wörtern außer nicht gesetzt und k.o
gesetzt und zwar rief es ihm zu okay
Boomer
und das war sozusagen der Beginn dieses
Boomer bashings von dem ich manchmal
denke das ist nicht gut wenn wir da
diese Fronten aufbauen deswegen rede ich
habe mich das so gestört dieser dieser
sozusagen dieser Pauschale Vorwurf wir
würden über die Jugend von heute es gibt
die Jugend von heute nicht und wir haben
gemacht und haben das hier chronisch
verwendet richtig folgendem Grund als
wir jung war waren war das eine stehende
Redewendung der älteren Generation über
die Jugend von heute zu glauben und
eigentlich der Begriff die Jugend von
heute fast ausgeschoben so sagt das ja
gar keiner mehr traut sich ja heute
heute machen wir ja folgendes wir machen
aus Generationen Markenartikel das fing
mit Generation X an und dann why und
dann Set das ist so ein Logo ja das also
das stimmt die die Generationen werden
immer kürzer das sind ja immer nur zehn
Jahre und die Millennials und was alles
kommt das sind ja immer so nur noch zehn
Jahre früher dauerte eine Generation
irgendwie 30 Jahre jetzt dauert es nur
noch zehn Jahre und sieht man kriegt
immer wieder neues Etikett aufgeklebt
und weiß was mich daran besonders stört
aus dem Marketing ne ja ja total ist
machen Marketing Spezialisten ist
soziologische Kategorie erstmal nee nee
das ist das geht darum wie kann man den
Leuten besser was verkaufen die
Generation Golf und so weiter also ich
höre ja oft in der Wirtschaft auch
sofort Kriege ne wo also Soziologen die
so Marketing machen und so das
Untersuchen ne in den Zielgruppen und
Altersgruppen und so und da werden 100
Kategorien erfunden ne die Lust betonten
unter 30-Jährigen und die
über 40-jährigen Schubladen erfunden und
lauter Klischees produzieren ja und
damit wird dann geguckt für welche
relevante Zielgruppe kann man dann
bewerben und seine Sachen verkaufen aber
was mich absolut stört daran ist ich
fremde mit dem Begriff Generation
allgemein
ich habe mal in meinem Roman die
cosmonauten mich über den Begriff der
Generation lustig gemacht also zu einer
Generation zugehörig fühlt man sich ganz
vielleicht wenn man ganz jung ist da
kennt man auch seine Generation noch gar
nicht sondern man weiß nur dass man
irgendwie anders ist als die älteren
genau und Opas erfinden Generationen
damals die wir ja also so im
rückblickend
ja und jede Groschen kam in die Spardose
und so weiter und dadurch entsteht so
die Konstruktion einer Generation aber
je näher man an eine Generation ran
kommt umso kleiner wird sie wenn ich mal
überlege ich habe mit 99 anderen wir
waren glaube ich ziemlich genau 100 die
Abitur gemacht haben so wir waren also
sowas von einer Generation ne und noch
ein Milieu kamen alle aus der gleichen
Stadt und so
bei wie vielen von denen in meiner
gegenstufe habe ich das Gefühl gehabt
die sind irgendwie wie ich
die aller aller wichtigsten ich habe
auch damals gedacht die aller
allermeisten von denen die sind ganz
ganz anders als ich mit den verbindet
mich eigentlich außer der Tatsache dass
wir in die gleiche Klasse gegangen sind
im gleichen Schule waren uns was
eigentlich gar nichts die denken anders
die handeln anders die waren deutlich
anders erzogen als ich wir waren durch
ganz andere Einflüsse geprägt und im
Nachhinein muss man sagen ja hier ne wir
gehören zusammen wir sind eine
Generation die nee jede Generation
besteht aus ganz ganz vielen Menschen
die alle unterschiedlich sind und wenn
wir das so gerade machen wollen also
wenn wir aus so einem Wildwasserfluss
wie eine Generation das ist ein Kanal
machen ne der so künstlich begradigen
schönes Bild dann kommt einfach eine
Konstruktion aber raus die zu nichts
taugt ja es ist wahr ja und da baut sich
so eine so eine so eine seltsame Front
auf ja dann geht's plötzlich sozusagen
die Boomer ist ein Schimpfwort geworden
ich muss auch ehrlich sagen das
mittlerweile wahnsinnig stört ich habe
ich habe noch nicht von von Tillmann
Prüfer Kollege aus der von der Zeit der
hat ein ein leidenschaftliches eine
Hymne an die Boomer geschrieben ja sagte
darin irgendwie der Boomer sind das
Feindbild heute die sind angeblich zu
reich wir haben zu wenig Sinn für die
Umwelt dann kommt dein Freund Harald
Welzer und sagt meine Generation ja
Achtung hör mal genau zu das sind die
Fettaugen auf der Suppe die ihre
Generation jetzt auslöffeln muss das
müsste viel offensiver thematisiert
werden ich verstehe nicht warum man
immer noch so friedlich mit meiner
Generation umgeht die doch alles versaut
hat das sagt harald Welzer habe ich
verstehe aber warum das sagt nee ich
verstehe das auch aber ich kriege diese
Blume Diskussion hier in der kriminati
nicht mit ne also dass die Oma jetzt ein
allgemeines gesellschaftliches Feindbild
sind ist mir bislang ehrlich gesagt
nicht aufgefallen vielleicht weil ich
nicht mit den richtigen Leuten darüber
hast du nicht mitgekriegt doch da baut
sich was auf also ich erinnere mich
bevor ich gleich mal kommentiere das
erste Mal als Frank Schumacher noch
lebte
das und schrieb er ein Porträt ich meine
über Christian Wulff und da war noch
nicht Bundespräsident und da ging es
darum dass die Generation der Leute die
jetzt auf die 50 zugehen an den
Schlüsselpositionen der Politik sitzen
also jetzt Ministerpräsidenten sind und
führende Ämter im Staat übernehmen und
dann stellen die Frage was haben die
eigentlich bisher geleistet also
inwiefern haben sie die Welt bisher
besser gemacht und das waren sehr sehr
kluger Artikel und der lief darauf
hinaus dass eigentlich keine großen
politischen Visionen oder Konzepte von
dieser Generation ausgehen und
ausgegangen sind und damit meinte er
sich selber naja ist doch selber genau
in dem Alter gewesen also leben würde
wäre heute wahrscheinlich 65 oder so und
sich eben die Frage zu stellen sind wir
nicht die Generation die als erste schon
mit jungen Jahren mitgekriegt hat dass
der Klimawandel kommt dass wir
Ressourcen verbrauchen Gedanken und dass
wir die Generationen sind die eine Macht
gekommen ist und zum Teil noch an der
Macht ist und die letztlich unterm
Strich nichts besser gemacht hat sondern
wenn man sich die Öko Bilanz
zumindestens angucken die Dinge
schlechter gemacht hat dass das verstehe
das ist nur eine Frage
hätte diese Generation ist anders machen
können und ist es sozusagen ist der
Begriff Generation passend
verstehst du was kann ich denn dafür was
die anderen tun
also in den Sack einer Generation
gestopft zu werden tut jedem einzelnen
der da drin ist einfach Unrecht
ja irgendwie muss man es natürlich
kategorisieren und die Stoßrichtung um
dies da geht nicht um wie geht es ja
Harald Welzheim die ist ja klar also wir
sozusagen ist tatsächlich dass wir in
den letzten 20 30 Jahren ist in der Welt
fast nichts besser geworden und
ökologisch gesehen ist ganz ganz viele
schlimmer geworden natürlich haben wir
auf der einen Seite inzwischen überall
Fahrradwege die ist in meiner Jugend
noch nicht gab ja und Windräder gibt es
mittlerweile auch ziemlich viele und so
aber wenn man sich am anguckt wie groß
das Problem ist und wie wenig wir
geschafft haben da muss man sagen die
ganz große Wände und das große Umdenken
haben wir nicht hingekriegt und ja dem
Punkt in dem Punkt hat Harald definitiv
recht ja das stimmt gerade ein neues
Buch geschrieben
genau
was in Deutschland schief läuft und
würde wahrscheinlich auch wieder sagen
ganz viele davon hat unsere Generation
versaut ja genau aber weißt du was mich
daran stört es baut eine Front auf
und und das ist auch das Thema wenn du
sagst okay Boomer und dabei noch so die
Augen verdrehst und irgendwie nach links
oben oder rechts unten guckst dass das
ist genau dieser Sound der letzten Endes
so viel Zwietracht sieht und der uns am
Ende überhaupt nicht weiter bringt ja
Boomer als Feindbild der Jugend ich
halte mal dagegen also ne ja ist ein
echtes fein also
zu mir recht ja hast du einen blöden
Sohn mein Sohn macht das nicht nein
weißt du was hat er noch nie zu mir
gesagt wir wollen ihn jetzt nicht auf
dumme Gedanken bringen aber macht er
jetzt in unsere Söhne sind ja quasi
gleich alt könnt ihr das auch mit dem
gleichen recht sein ich bin sogar noch
mehr Boomer als du du bist ja schon so
einem Alter wo du schon so Homer fast
raus der personifizierte
ja aber aber gefühlt bin ich natürlich
genau einer dieser Boomer dabei
engagiere ich mich ökologisch wo es geht
versuche an einigermaßen korrekter
Mensch zu sein was Ökologie angeht und
so weiter hat meine Wärmepumpen und
meine Photovoltaik und so weiter und ich
mag das und deswegen sage ich auch immer
bitte baut doch nicht diese Front auf
ich weißt du nur weil ich manche Dinge
dieser jüngeren Generation nicht
verstehe heißt das ja noch um lange
nicht dass sie deshalb falsch sind die
sind anders und es ist ihr gutes Recht
anders zu sein deswegen
wenn sie nicht anders werden stell dir
das mal vor so könntest du Kinder die
den ganzen Tag in der Kühltruhe sitzen
und Schnarchen ja und die Platten ihre
Eltern auch das meine ich doch wurde
sogar dass diese jüngeren Generationen
ja
tendenziell ein viel zu positives
Verhältnis zu der Generation davor haben
weil ihre Idole und und und vieles von
dem was sie als Lebensstil gut finden
und was was ich was stammt ja aus dieser
bumer genau aber sie sind ich weiß und
sie sind aber zum Teil
wahnsinnig resigniert sie sind irgendwie
traurig und ich denke da ich und ich
bemühe mich immer sie zu verstehen wir
machen eine ganze Folge darüber gemacht
ja darüber welche Schwierigkeiten diese
Generation Set hat und für mich ist
immer so das was über allem steht jede
Generation baut sich ihre ganz eigene
Hölle ja und mit der müssen wir
irgendwie zurechtkommen und in der
müssen wir irgendwie leben und nur weil
ich es nicht verstehe heißt es noch
lange nicht dass es diese Hölle nicht
gibt und dieser Vorwürfe ihr habt ja so
gut und wir haben alles aufgebaut ja und
ihr habt quasi von uns profitiert weil
wir einen ungeheuren Wohlstand
geschaffen haben und er sitzt sie da wie
die Made im Speck und erklärt uns die
ganze Zeit das alles doof ist fliegt
aber trotzdem mit uns gemütlich in den
Urlaub genießt euer schönes Leben und
versucht euch irgendwie auszubalancieren
und erklärt uns gleichzeitig dass wir
den Planeten zerstört haben ja das kann
man so könnte man so machen tun ich kann
man so machen und wenn man sich ich tue
mich ja wie gesagt mit den Generationen
schwer aber wenn man sagt ein
Mentalitätswechsel denn nicht bei jedem
aber bei vielen da ist
wir gehören einer Generation an die
geglaubt hat man könnte mit Politik die
Welt verändern und intechnik allerdings
können wir Technik und das merkt man bei
euch Buhmann ich bin ja raus bei euch
bumern merkt man das bis heute dieser
Jacke bei meiner unglaublichen Technik
also dieser Glaube dass irgendwie wir
werden schon irgendwas Scheiße
wir könnten die Dinge verändern jetzt
muss man sagen
fällt das Leben der Boomer in eine Zeit
in der die der politische
Veränderungswille erlosch weil man ja
eigentlich in der optimalen Gesellschaft
leben also bei mir war das ja speziell
ne du weißt ja ich komme aus dem linken
Elternhaus und bin so ein bisschen
darauf vorbereitet worden die Welt
Revolution irgendwann erwachsen bin und
muss dann sehen dass spätestens mit dem
Mauerfall und eigentlich schon deutlich
früher ja der Bedarf an Weltrevolution
sich erledigt hatte und dass man
eigentlich jetzt in der besten aller
Welten angelangt ist und jetzt geht es
eigentlich nur noch darum den Wohlstand
weiter zu mehren und vielleicht ein
bisschen dafür zu sorgen dass die Kluft
zur dritten Welt nicht zu groß wird aber
eigentlich ist leben hier in der besten
aller Welten oder wie Francis Fukuyama
gesagt hat am Ehezeit Ende der
Geschichte jetzt kommt nichts
grundlegend anderes mehr
das heißt die gleiche Generation die
noch in diesem Geist erzogen ist man
kann mit Politik die Dinge verändern hat
eigentlich das Hauptaugenmerk darauf
gelenkt die Dinge nicht zu verändern
sondern zu bewahren es sollte immer so
weitergehen und dann kommt die
ökologische Dimension und macht diesen
denken einen Strich durch die Rechnung
und deswegen hat die Boomer Generation
aber auch die noch älteren sich immer
innerlich dagegen gesperrt wahrhaben zu
wollen dass die beste der Welt in den
Untergang führt
und dieses schwierige denken das ist
dieser unabgeschlossene Denkprozess der
diese Generation bestimmt die jüngere
Generation dagegen die sieht sich mit
Problemen im globalen Maßstab
konfrontiert von denen sich eigentlich
überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann dass sie
irgendwie auch nur lösbar sein können
und deswegen habe ich mich sehr sehr
gefreut als mit Fridays for future eine
Bewegung aufkam die wieder Optimismus
versprühte
das war also seit 68 hatte es so ein
gesellschaftlichen Optimismus nicht mehr
gegeben aber der hat natürlich nicht
alle entzündet und alle entfacht ich
sehe das auch bis hin zu meinem eigenen
Sohn das so ein bisschen so ein Axel
zucken ist dass man denkt die Probleme
der Welt sind zu groß als dass wir sie
irgendwie noch lösen können ja und die
sehen auch dass das ist schwierig wird
die sind ja auch klug und die verstehen
das ganz genau ich muss noch mal ganz
kurz weil sonst wird das so geht's immer
auf euch bumer ja ich bin ja wie gesagt
gehört
von der Zeit bricht in einem total guten
Stück eine Interesse für euch boomerig
hat ja beste Generation aller Zeiten und
sagt ich liebe die Boomer ich bin Ihnen
dankbar alles was ich im Leben erfahren
habe jede Phase meiner Identitätssuche
meine sogenannte will der Jugend all das
konnte ich durchleben weil Boomer es mir
vorgemacht hatten und es gibt den den
Soziologen Zukunftsforscher Thomas dojen
den kennst du und der der beschäftigt
sich viel mit liebe Grüße übrigens an
der Stelle ganz schlauer Mann
beschäftigt sich viel mit
reichtumsforschung auch von Thomas weiß
ich zum Beispiel dass Milliardäre ist
sehr interessant die haben kein Neid
Problem weil weil du jenseits der
neidgrenze bist ja wenn du hörst wenn du
Milliardär bist dann hast du kein
Problem mehr mit billige night Reflexen
weil sozusagen die Erkenntnis sich Bahn
bricht dass man da hinten sowieso nicht
kommt und deswegen muss man auf den
Typen auf nicht neidisch sein umgekehrt
ich behaupte das gleiche gibt's bei
Hartz IV Empfänger auch das mag sein
weil die auch jetzt kein kein Teil einer
mal rivalisierenden
statusgesellschaft sind also man geht
nicht auf der Leiter die Sprossen hoch
die einen weil sie ganz oben angekommen
sind und die anderen weil sie nicht auf
die Leiter kommen sondern der
kategorische Komparativ der den Neid
auslöst dann Kate
Problem fein fein fein der kategorische
Komparativ an wie wie fällt dir sowas
ein spontan jetzt mal eben so das ist
schon mal gestellt habe ich schon mal
geschrieben in die Kunst keine Egoist zu
sein habe ich meinen Kapitel der
kategorische Komparativ das gefällt mir
aber was auf Thomas schreibt es sehr
interessant Boomer gehören nicht nur zur
ersten Generation die ohne ideologische
Gewissheiten aufwächst ja sondern er
sagt sie sind gleichzeitig auch die
letzten die von dem Glauben durchdrungen
sind für jedes Problem gibt es eine
Lösung und er sagt die Boomer waren die
Treiber und die Nutznießer das
Wirtschaftswachstums ohne sich allzu
tief in irgendwelche ideologischen
System Kämpfe entwickeln zu müssen und
der macht das dann noch mal ganz konkret
klar wie sehr diese Boomer Generation
die die Welt von heute wirklich geprägt
hat ja er sagt in dieser Zeit wurde
praktisch alles geschaffen was unsere
hedonistische Popkultur sozusagen heute
ausmacht ja die Mitglieder von Queen
sind Boomer Bruce Springsteen ist Boomer
Steve Spielberg ist Boomer Stephen King
ist Boomer und ohne den Boomer Steve
Jobs hätte die junge Generation von
heute kein einziges iPhone und auch
keine digitale Musik
Bill Gates der ist kein Microsoft Office
ja nur als Beispiel Techno kommt von
Buhmann das was in Berliner Bergheim
aufgelegt wird es haben alles irgendwann
mal bumer erfunden und so weiter und so
weiter also das heißt diese verteufelte
bumer Generation er hat eine Menge
gemacht und dann sagt Thomas es ist
unfassbar provokant man könnte als bumer
auch die nachfolgende Generation einfach
mal fragen was habt ihr eigentlich
erfunden
ja aber vielleicht haben wir ihn auch
keinen Raum gegeben also ich würde mal
sagen diese ganzen habe ich auch ganz
cool ne die ganze Jugendkultur also Punk
über die diversen Musikrichtungen und
alles was du da gerade angesprochen hast
und die Moden und die Bands und diese
ganzen Kultfiguren und so weiter sind
entstanden in einer Lehre die sind
nämlich entstanden gegen den
konservativen Mief des Adenauer
Deutschlands und vor allen Dingen die
meisten die hier aufgezählt das waren
keine deutschen ja aber gegen das
mccasia Amerika ja also gegen gegen eine
eine eine völlig Spaß befreite ja
religiös aufgeheizte misstrauische Welt
wofür die Jugend kein Platz vorgesehen
war außer das Leben ihre Eltern zu
kopieren so und die hatten also ein
unglaubliches Bedürfnis ganz anders sein
zu wollen als ihre Eltern ja und das war
natürlich auch ein wichtiges Motiv
beachten 68
und eine solche Steppe haben unsere
Kinder nicht vorgefunden sondern die
haben einen ein Vielfaches
aufgegliederte Biotope vorgefunden und
ich meine was wäre denn die Alternative
gewesen also als die die Popmusik und
die Rockmusik und so weiter entstand wie
sah den Musik 20 Jahre vorher aus
also da gab es sozusagen die offiziell
ein bisschen unterdrückte unterdrückte
Jazzmusik ja und genau und parallel zu
68er Revolution in Deutschland Italien
Frankreich und so weiter legten die
Eltern Heinze Platten ein Tier und
Förster Filme das war das
der försterfilme noch ein bisschen davor
ja genau
weißt du ich denke manchmal oder ich
wundere mich manchmal dass die die
jungen dass die junge Generation sich
nicht über andere Dinge wirklich viel
viel mehr aufregt also ein Gedanke
Roman Herzog 2010 in der Süddeutschen
Zeitung zitier mal ich fürchte wir sehen
die Vorboten einer rentner-demokratie
die älteren werden immer mehr stimmt
alle Parteien nehmen über proportional
Rücksicht auf sie stimmt und das könnte
am Ende in die Richtung gehen dass die
Älteren die Jüngeren ausplündern Roman
Herzog 2010 spricht etwas aus von dem
man heute sagen muss 2023 genauso war
wie damals und es wird immer wahrer in
weiter gekommen
ja ja also ich Rente ist ja eines meiner
lieblingsthemente klingt ja nur auf dem
ersten Blick langweilig hinter die
Kulissen kommen sieht man ein
unglaubliches Drama ja das längst da ist
das nicht auf uns zukommt sondern das
Links da ist ne weil diese junge
Generation über die wir hier sprechen
und jungen Generationen nicht in der
Lage sein wird unsere Renten zu bezahlen
darf ich ganz kurz die Zahlen da mache
ich ja das ist wirklich ihre
statistisches Bundesamt ja 21
30,75 Millionen Boomer versus
11,57 Millionen in der Generation
zwischen 96 und 2012 musst du dir
vorstellen bedeutet
ein Rentner richtig so und da das de
facto nicht geht das weiß auch jeder
machen sich auch die Jugendlichen so
viel Sorgen oh Gott wie wir kriegen nie
mir nie eine Rente ihr kriegt nur
deswegen kann ich immer sagen keine
Rente weil wir das System nicht
verändern das Umlage System 1957
eingeführt war damals klug Weise und
richtig und es hat viele Jahrzehnte ein
sehr guten Dienst getan unter der
Voraussetzung dass sie Demografie sich
nicht verändert der berühmte Satz von
Adenauer ja Kinder kriegen die Leute
immer Kinder
Leute immer genau
Voraussetzung dass die langen
Arbeitszeiten erhalten bleiben von
früher unter der Voraussetzung dass man
sich nicht früh verwenden lässt unter
der Voraussetzung dass die Leute im
jungen Jahren abonnieren Arbeitsmarkt
kommen und nicht erst mit 28 oder mit 30
weil so viele studieren ich könnte jetzt
eine Liste von zehn Punkten durchgehen
die alle neben der Demografie auch noch
eine Rolle spielen warum dieses System
kaputt ist und ich habe das glaube ich
auch hier im Podcast schon mal gesagt
wir bezuschussen das Rentensystem mit
100 Milliarden Euro im Jahr
wohlgemerkteltes
in Richtung ein Drittel also Viertel und
Tendenz stark steigen genau ja also über
100 Milliarden das heißt also jeder
vierte Euro die in der Stadt zur
Verfügung steht geht nicht in die
Finanzierung der Rente finanziert wird
die Rente durch die Abgaben der
Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitgeber sondern die
Bezuschussung zur Finanzierung genau und
Tendenz massiv steigend und ist das ein
Wahlkampf Thema wird darüber in
Deutschland
die Augen zu ja und wir kippen in dem
Punkt da hat Harald wirklich recht in
dem Punkt kippen wir der Generation ja
einen Haufen Schrott vor die Füße und
die muss dann ein System komplett neu
erfinden weil das ist nicht reparabel
also dadurch dass man sagt ja da müsste
halt nicht bis 65 arbeiten da müssen wir
das Verschieben ja was so die
Arbeitgeberverbände und so ein paar Unis
und so immer sagen was für ein Blödsinn
angesichts dessen in der
Wissensgesellschaft weißt du wo ich
jetzt schon sehe wie viele Leute in
meiner Generation ihren Job kaum noch
mehr machen können weil sie den
technischen Herausforderung nicht mehr
gewachsen sind die will niemand mehr
lange haben ich sehe um mich herum Leute
die sind 60 zum Teil sogar drunter die
kriegen Angebote von ihren Firmen die
sie nicht Ableben wollen weil man die
Leute loswerden will weil die den
Herausforderung auch nicht mehr
gewachsen sind
und ich meine wie kann man denn dann
behaupten wir müssen alle bis 70
arbeiten entweder du bist noch in einem
harten körperlichen Job dann kannst du
nicht bis 70 arbeiten
oder du bist in einen Job wo du einfach
den Laden nur noch aufhältst ja im
Management oder was auch immer oder
Logistik oder sowas weil du einfach
nicht mehr Herr der Lage bist das heißt
das ist doch keine Lösung du kannst doch
nicht jeden ewig arbeiten lassen es ist
totaler Quatsch ja ist richtig ja ich
meine das ist die demografische
Katastrophe die sozusagen über allem
steht aber auch vorne in der Politik in
der ersten Reihe ich meine die das mal
anschaust Amerika ich habe dieser Tage
wieder Milch gesehen das ist der einer
der größten Widersacher von Barack Obama
gewesen wenn man Barack Obama auf mich
mcConnell anspricht dann kriegt er heute
noch
richtig hohen Blutdruck war derjenige
der die Politik von Trump ganz brutal
durchgeboxt hat das ist ein wirklich
alter Mann der jetzt mehrfach das zweite
Mal jetzt bei Pressekonferenzen der ist
einfach eingefroren ist einfach
sozusagen
virtuellen Herzinfarkt ja also du mer
der wird ja auch wenn er sonst redet
leicht wahrnehmungsverzögert und da gibt
es diese Momente ja dann hat der
Synkopen Synkopen also für kurze Zeit
komplett weg ja also dann bewirbt sich
um das Präsidentenamt ein Mann der wenn
er dann irgendwann am Ende seine
Laufbahn wäre Joe Biden ist er 86 Jahre
alt sein vermutlicher Herausforderer
Donald Trump ist aktuell glaube ich 76
Jahre alt putin ist 70 ist 69 Modi der
indische premier ist glaube ich 72 Olaf
Scholz ist 64 ist sozusagen der wenn man
in diesem Kategorien denkt gerade
so das heißt Amerika nicht nur mit
schmale ja
beiden Trump wenn du nancylosi siehst ja
ist auch glaube ich 80 oder so und die
Leute sind in einem Zustand dass das
will man so nicht sehen und man fragt
sich immer wie kann es sein ja dass wir
auf diese Schlacht der gerontokraten
einlassen am Amerika wird an der
ortokratie man könnte sich doch nie
vorstellen können dass Amerika den
gleichen Weg geht wie die alte
Sowjetunion als der Kreise brechen hier
starb ja stand wer zur Verfügung Juri
Andropow ja der der ehemalige kgb-chef
richtig ja der zu dem Zeitpunkt glaube
ich seinen 80 Geburtstag auch schon
hinter sich hatte und erlebte auch nur
noch ein Jahr oder zwei und dann kam
Jenko der war glaube ich noch älter der
lebte nur ein Jahr richtig also da
konnte man ja sagen symbolisch war das
ne da ist ein Staat völlig kaputt das
hat allerletzte aufgebaut da sind nur
noch die wetterahnen übrig geblieben die
einzigen die irgendwie noch daran
glauben oder die man in die erste Reihe
stellen kann und so so jetzt ist
natürlich die USA völlig anderes System
aber man fragt sich warum ist das
phänomenologische Bild so ähnlich also
warum passiert das gleiche ja warum
warum lassen sich junge
Erklärungen also einerseits liegt das
natürlich an der Popularität von Donald
Trump der diese Partei in Form einer
feindlichen Übernahme muss man ja sagen
gekapert haben und ihre die restliche
Partei ist kaputt richtig und bei den
Demokraten liegt es daran dass eine ganz
schwere Frage darin besteht was wäre
denn eigentlich jemand der demokratische
Politik verkörpern könnte denn hier
passiert es einer Partei dass sie in
lauter Teil auseinander fliegt jetzt
haben wir bei unseren Parteien ja auch
schon erlebt irgendwann war nicht mehr
klar wofür steht die SPD na da gab es
immer noch in der SPD so ein paar die
sich als links bezeichneten aber da die
SPD wenn sie regiert ja nie links ist
ist natürlich auch starke
Wirtschaftsflügel inzwischen gab und
dann irgendwie war überhaupt nicht mehr
klar was ist das überhaupt noch
schwierige Gewerkschaften noch eine
Rolle wenn die alte Arbeitswelt
verschwindet und und und und die
Demokraten haben ähnliches Problem es
gibt ein paar richtig linke bei den
Demokraten linker als früher ich glaube
bis auf George schmecken der mal glaube
ich Nixen angetreten ist kenne ich
eigentlich richtig linken Demokraten und
davon gibt es inzwischen ja wieder
einige Bernie Sanders hat so vorgemacht
und da gibt es auch junge Leute die so
sind die sind aber nicht mehr als fähig
innerhalb der Demokraten dann gibt es
viele die der Finanzindustrie nahe
stehen das sind ganz ganz andere Leute
die die wollen mit Links überhaupt gar
nichts zu tun haben dann gibt es auch
die Leute die die die
kulturellen ich drücke mich jetzt mal
vorsichtig aus kulturellen Fortschritt
Tendenzen also die ganzen Fragen nach
Frauenrechten und so weiter zu zentralen
politischen Inhalten machen möchten und
wenn du diese verschiedenen Gruppen
siehst dann siehst du das sind alles
Vertreter von spachten Programmen du
hast aber kaum jemand der das ganze
diesen diversen Laden noch in der Mitte
ein kann und weil die sich untereinander
nicht einigen können schicken Sie dieses
Fossil beiden wieder in ihrer Seite
und warum kann der Mann eigentlich nicht
davon lassen ich meine ich stelle mir
auch immer die Frage wie muss man
eigentlich sein wenn man glaubt in dem
Alter der passende Mann zu sein
und auch seitdem wenn man auch noch weiß
dass man derjenige ist der von einem
wahrscheinlich noch am wenigsten Trump
verhindern kann dass man dann trotzdem
noch mal antritt ja das ist ich glaube
Roy Wood ist in amerikanischer Komiker
hat als als beiden seiner Leute
Kandidatur angekündigt hat sagt es ist
total bizari die Franzosen gehen auf die
Straße und zertrümmern das halbe Land
weil sie keinen Bock haben bis 64 zu
arbeiten und wir haben einen 80-jährigen
der uns anfleht ihm weitere vier Jahre
Arbeit okay das ist das ist natürlich
schöne Formulierung aber
noch mal warum ist das so etwas passiert
da gerade ist das einfach sozusagen
Ausdruck auch dieser demografischen
Katastrophe übrigens gleich nennen die
Dinge sind wie sie sind ja aber dieser
demografischen Situation in die wir da
reinkommen wie werden einfach wirklich
alte gesellschaftschaften oder halten
darf als zweifelt ein paar alte wirklich
an ihren Freunden und Privilegien fest
und beißen jeden Weg jeden Jungen Weg
der irgendwie versucht nach vorne zu
kommen was vielleicht stimmt beides aber
ich finde der erstaunlichste Befund ist
die Schwäche der Junge in den USA
die viele sind nur die Amerikaner sind
die die sich mit jungen Präsidenten
verbunden hat da fährt natürlich ein
allererster Linie Kennedy oder sowas ein
so ein Kennedy stand ja viele Obama auch
relativ jung genau beide beide für ein
Kulturwandel der im Fall von Kennedy
sehr viel umfangreicher war weil das war
sozusagen das Abräumen des alten
konservativen Amerikas und dann
überhaupt der war ja sozusagen der der
das Symbol für den Einzug von
Jugendkultur in Alltagssprache für für
eine absolute Kulturrevolution kann man
ja sein
auch wenn er das vielleicht nicht als
Person alles verkörpert hat so war er
doch sozusagen die Symbolfigur dafür das
war bei Obama schon deutlich weniger
weil nicht so richtig klar war worin das
neue jetzt bestehen würde aber trotzdem
gab es da noch mal diese Hoffnung und
diesen Schwung der so eine echte
Begeisterung die die Menschen erfasst
hat
ja ich meine wo drin soll die echte
Begeisterung für beiden bestehen ja und
warum sind die die begeistern könnten
und man die USA verfügt ja mit
Sicherheit über viele Talente warum
setzen die sich nicht durch das verstehe
ich ihm nicht weil und dann und dann
sitzt da dieser Trump wieder und gibt
dann wieder Interviews und lästert über
den alten gebrechlichen Joe Biden und
ich denke okay ein alter Mann macht
einen anderen alten Mann dafür fertig
dass ein alter Mann ist
komparativer als der andere
und solange er kann 100 mal sagen wie
alt bleiben keiner mehr darüber nach wie
alt war weißt du was total irre ist es
gibt es gibt sogar Berechnungen darüber
also anhand des Lebensstils der beiden
ja beide sind Abstinenzler Frau trinken
wenig Alkohol echt
Rauchen beide nicht machen ihren Sport
und so weiter dann dann schaut man sich
doch so ein bisschen hingehen Pool an
und sagt na ja
also das ist schon okay wenn die das
machen weil der Trump hat die
Wahrscheinlichkeit 90 zu werden und der
beiden sogar 91 und ist es also völlig
in Ordnung so so so säuft man sich so
die Welt zurecht ja und redet sich
irgendwie schön das war uralte Typen
jetzt irgendwie die die die größte und
einflussreichste Nationen dieses
Planeten irgendwie wir sollten jetzt
einen kleinen Einwand machen damit wir
hier nicht so als alten feindlich
rüberkommen
wäre ja mindestens genauso alt gewesen
wenn er nicht sogar noch ein bisschen
älter war also der dürfte auch deutlich
gemacht sein und da muss man einfach
auch sagen und das ist mir auch wichtig
weil das ist ein wichtiger Gedanke für
diesen Podcast die Frage wie alt man
biologisch ist sagt nicht unbedingt
zwingend so viel darüber aussieht im
Kopf ist also wenn ich mich selber Frage
wie alt ich bin ne ich denke über mein
Alter nicht nach aber wenn ich
nachmittags Schläfe mache dann kriege
ich danach immer so ein so eine ganz
minimale kleine depressive Phase
genau 10 Minuten 10 Minuten bis der
Blutzuckerspiegel wieder steigt also 10
Minuten bist du richtig ja bin ich mit
der Welt
durch und dann fällt mir immer mein
alter ein weil ich denke mal es gibt
noch so 100 Dinge die ich machen will
und ich denke na ja aber so viel Zeit
ist dafür auch nicht und dass ich so in
meinem Inneren Selbstwertgefühl ne wenn
ich so schlafe oder Träume bin ich
irgendwie so Anfang 30 Mitte das auch ne
ja und das das behält man so bei und es
gibt manchmal Situationen im Leben da
denke ich mein Gott du bist ja immer
noch 15 ja also das finde ich mich
selber irgendwie auf eine positive Art
und Weise albern und bin froh dass es
kein anderer mitkriegt und dann gibt es
andere Dinge da war ich schon als Kind
zeitlos reisenhaft ja also im
Kindergarten
war ein Tag gewesen sicher
abgeschafft nee nicht weil ich nicht den
alter Mann übernommen habe aber andere
Sachen also wenn ich glücklich war mein
Zimmer saß und meine Briefmarken
sortiert hat hätte ich auch 80 sein
können
also deswegen ist es ja schwierig also
jemand nur aufgrund eines
fortgeschrittenen Alters sozusagen als
unpassendes Personal zu sagen deswegen
ich bin auch dagegen dass man sagt oh
guck mal der ist schon so alt das muss
jetzt mal verjüngt werden oder wenn
Leute die irgendwo arbeiten man sagt er
ist jetzt 60 ja der muss jetzt mal
ersetzt werden oder einen Mann ist muss
er durch eine junge Frau ersetzt werden
oder so die entscheidende Frage ist
schon wie alt oder wie jung man im Kopf
ist das ist ja das ist kein sozusagen
Plädoyer gegen die alten aber es ist ein
Plädoyer für die Jungen und ich finde
eine Generation oder überhaupt junge
Menschen Amerikas ein junges Land nein
Vergleich zu Europa ein sehr junges Land
Europa wird 2050 im Schnitt irgendwo bei
Mitte 50 sein wir wir vergreisen
tatsächlich und wenn es irgendwann mal
eine europäische Armee geben sollte dann
wird das eine durch und durchs klotische
ja und mit Bewegung durchsetzte Armee
sein was sie da noch wirklich leisten
können ist noch mal ganz andere Frage in
Amerika sieht die Welt anders aus die
Amerikaner werden auch im Jahre 2050
irgendwo 36 37 Jahren sein das sagt
zumindest die Demografie und mein Punkt
in den vielen Einwanderern ja wegen den
vielen Einwanderern und die Frage ist
natürlich wenn du wenn das sind die
Leute die die Hoffnung repräsentieren
die Leute die die mitten im Leben sind
ja so so wie wir es jetzt gerade auch
noch sind aber das wird dann irgendwann
weniger und und diese Leute brauchen
doch Leuchttürme die brauchen doch
Figuren zu denen sie aufschauen können
Menschen mit denen sie sich
identifizieren können und es tut mir
wirklich leid aber Nancy Pelosi ist da
nicht die Frau die einen 20-jährigen
jungen Amerikaner dazu inspirieren wird
irgendwie dieses Land ganz großartig zu
finden oder bestimmte Politik zu gehen
ja zum Beispiel und das Gefühl dass
natürlich entsteht ist da da halten ein
paar ein paar alte sehr einflussreiche
Leute haben einfach mit allen Mitteln an
ihrer Macht fest und lassen keinen
durchkommen und das ist natürlich echt
schwierig und ich frage mich sowieso was
das für eine irgendwann mal sein wird ja
die da gerade entsteht
Italien ist das Land mit der niedrigsten
Geburtenrate glaube ich fast auf dem
Planeten gegen das Klischee das
Italiener ihre Kinder so lieben und die
lieben sich vielleicht deswegen tun sie
das tun sie weil sie so wenige sind
Zusammenhang je mehr Kinder eine
Gesellschaft hat umso weniger geringer
ist die Bedeutung dieser Kinder für ihre
Eltern die italienische Geburtenrate ne
zur Zeit der nationalen Einigung
Italiens also reden davon 1861 60 rum ja
gab es 800.000 Geburten jedes Jahr bei
26 Millionen Einwohner heute hat Italien
fast 60 Millionen Einwohner bei nicht
einmal 400.000 Babys übrigens auch eine
wohlstandsfolge muss man auch dazu sagen
arme Länder haben im Regelfall deutlich
mehr Kinder pass auf weltweit auch total
interessant und wie schnell das auch
geht ne inzwischen gibt es weltweit mehr
Menschen über 65 als Menschen unter fünf
Jahren
der Länder in der Welt ne ganz kurz
haben inzwischen eine Reproduktionsrate
ja die kleiner ist als die Zahl die
nötig wäre um die Menschheit sozusagen
zu erhalten mit anderen Worten wir
schaffen uns ab wir sterben
ich meine wir sind jetzt ja wir sind 8
Milliarden und das riesen Problem ja ist
Überbevölkerung ja also noch wächst ja
die Weltbevölkerung und sie wächst immer
noch relativ schnell ja also da ist doch
froh über die Nachricht aus jedem Land
wo die Bevölkerung nicht weg wächst ja
aber in Japan zum Beispiel als eine
unglaublich hochbetagte Gesellschaft die
japanische Bevölkerung schrumpft in
einem rekordtemposition ja aber das
finde ich super also wenn ja
wann haben sie nicht enger Raum versucht
da mal mit der U-Bahn zu fahren da wirst
du von jemanden reingedrückt der
Schaffner presst dich da rein Japan ist
wahnsinnig überbevölkert dass sie die
alte Nachricht die es gibt dass da die
Zahl der Menschen sich reduzieren die
Zahl der Japaner ist im letzten Jahr
fast um eine zurückgegangen sind 122
Millionen vor ja das sagst du so wer
pflegt die alten Leute was passiert mit
den üben wenn ich das die alten Leute in
Japan von Japanern gepflegt werden
du weißt Japan ist ein sehr isoliertes
Land da kommen die lassen nicht so viele
Leute von außen rein früher haben sie
ganz ganz viele Leute aus Korea
eingelassen
ja pass auf Südkorea also wir haben ja
gerne auch wenn man so mit mit
Politikern sozialpolitikern und so
weiter redet
rentenpolitikern redet dann sagen die
die ja gut da kommen dann in diese
ganzen Fachkräfte irgendwoher und so
weiter und die holen uns dann schon und
ich denke da manchmal woher genau sollen
die eigentlich jetzt eine kommen diese
ganzen top qualifizierten von dem wir da
manchmal so alle gemeinsam träumen wo
kommen die her aus Südkorea kommt die
nicht in Südkorea geht's mittlerweile
Regierungsprogramme die den Leuten sagen
pass auf geht mal abends früher nach
Hause es gibt Tage an denen die Lichter
im Büro um 18 Uhr aus sein müssen in der
Hoffnung dass die Leute nach Hause gehen
und sich dann melden mit sich selbst
beschäftigen sie vielleicht sogar aber
sie kriegen trotzdem keine Kinder ja ich
will das noch wahnsinnig gut dass das
bislang nur eine Aufforderung ist aber
dass sie nicht ja verstanden genau das
ist nur eine Aufforderung ist und dass
sie nicht ein Video Beweis antreten
müssen ja dass sie die Zeit auch
entsprechend sinnvoll genutzt haben das
wäre ja der nächste Schritt
ist doch nicht der Punkt ist doch nicht
dass wir nicht weniger werden dürfen es
ist gut wenn wir weniger werden aber wir
müssen die Probleme lösen die wir haben
wenn wir weniger werden und es ist doch
nicht so wenn jetzt in Deutschland eine
Million mehr Kinder geboren würden das
ja dann eine Million mehr Altenpfleger
hätten
sondern das große Problem ist das
Altenpflege in Deutschland nicht der
attraktive Beruf ist den er sein müsste
wenn wir mehr Leute haben wollen die
darin arbeiten also das rein über die
Zahlen immer zu machen also der ist das
ist eine ganz eigenartige Angewohnheit
die wir da haben wir versuchen mit Hilfe
der Statistik an Probleme ranzugehen die
kreative Lösungen brauchen ja das wäre
immer mehr werden müssen und dann noch
mehr mehr und noch mehr mehr und noch
mehr mehr das kann doch keinen nicht
sinnvoll sein ja nee ich ich will auf
was anderes hinaus Richard ähm wenn du
eine Bevölkerung hast die weniger wird
und deswegen verstehe ich schon dass
dann Politiker die zuständig sind dass
die dann plötzlich sehr alarmiert sind
du hast dann plötzlich Landschaften leer
stehende Häuser du hast du hast
verlassene Häuser du hast ganze
Landstriche die einfach so ein Völker
sie fahren mal durch Bulgarien kannst du
dir das Anschauen die Immigration aus
Osteuropa ist an sich nichts Neues in
mein nach 1989 also nach dem zusammen
Einbruch des großen Sowjetimperiums sind
ganz ganz viele Leute einfach
weggegangen das hat aber was gemacht und
der der sozusagen der Einschlag dieser
demografischen Entwicklung die ganzen
Jungen sind einfach weggegangen aus
Rumänien aus Moldau zum Beispiel wo wir
kürzlich waren und so weiter und das hat
und das ist schon interessant aus
zentral und Osteuropa eine der ethnisch
homogensten Regionen der Welt gemacht
und das stellt diese Regionen vor
unglaubliche Probleme also der Zuzug
nicht attraktiv ist ne ja ja die
Menschen schön unter sich genau genau
und dann geht's zum Beispiel um die
Frage ist auch Demokratie ne nochmal zum
Schluss ein Gedanke er hat ivank viele
Gedanken darüber gemacht das finde ich
total interessant
du musst dann irgendwann musst du den
Arbeitsmarkt öffnen das heißt du musst
erst mal gesellschaftlich verhandeln
okay wir brauchen jetzt Zuwanderung wo
soll die herkommen welche Leute wollen
wir da eigentlich wir haben gerade
gesprochen über also die Südkoreaner
sind nicht die kommen die haben selber
ein riesiges demografisches Problem die
Japaner sind auch nicht können uns auch
keine Leute schicken Chinesen schrumpfen
mittlerweile auch die haben auch einen
demografisches Problem und und und und
Afrika möchte man in Russland nicht so
gerne haben ja auch deswegen weil wir
wir sind Träumen ja immer von den ganzen
hochqualifizierten das heißt wir werden
uns die Mühe machen müssen mit den
Leuten die kommen mit denen müssen wir
arbeiten und denen müssen wir gleich die
Chance geben die müssen wir ausbilden
das ist die Wahrheit also diese Idee da
kommen irgendwo diese top ausgebildeten
Facharbeiter und dann wird das schon
Quatsch vergiss es ja genau spricht aber
keiner wirklich immer genervt also ein
Jürgens was auch immer heute macht immer
wieder Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen mit seinem doofen
die Kinder statt Inder so ja und von
wegen die ihnen da kriegen wir gar nicht
ja völliger Blödsinn also der war schon
die Alarm als damals
die Koreaner Südkorea ne die haben
glaube ich 200 Milliarden in Maßnahmen
geschätzt gesteckt die dazu führen
sollten dass die Koreaner mehr Kinder
kriegen es hat nicht funktioniert du
kannst nicht Menschen gegen ihren Willen
dazu zwingen mehr Kinder zu kriegen die
Chinesen versuchen es jetzt auch ihre
ein Kind Politik ist längst aufgeweicht
die können mittlerweile drei Kinder
haben machen sie aber nicht ja
emanzipierte Frauen also die
Gesellschaft wo es ein schnelles
Wohlstandswachstum gibt ne was in China
in den letzten 20 25 Jahren so war das
in Südkorea wo wir jetzt länger darüber
gesprochen haben ganz massiv war ein
Land das über lange Zeit ein riesigen
wirtschaftsbum gehabt hat in solchen
Gesellschaft wo die Leute sehen dass sie
sich eine enorme Perspektive und eine
deutliche materielle Verbesserung
erreichen können da versagt der
Kinderwunsch
ja weil man weil man dann will man nur
eine oder zwei Kinder haben und bloß
nicht das was man gewonnen hat quasi
durch die große Zahl der Kinder an die
man das dann weitergibt wieder zu
diffundieren also es ist eine ganz ganz
normale Entwicklung die so ist aber ich
glaube am Ende läuft das Ganze nicht
darüber dass man mehr Kinder kriegt
sondern dass man Gesellschaft
umorganisiert und da sind wir wahnsinnig
schlecht drin wir hatten vorhin das
Beispiel Rente wir können über das
Gesundheitssystem genau das gleiche
sagen und letztlich versuchen wir über
Zuwanderung und über mehr Kinder
Probleme zu lösen die man vielleicht
auch anders lösen kann ja gibt gibt zum
Beispiel auch wenn du dich erinnerst
gerade jüngst gab es auch immer so diese
Polemik da wird der deutsche Pass
verdammt ja dann denke ich immer okay
können wir gerne machen wir können gerne
diese Debatten genauso führen aber was
macht das mit denen die dann hier
reinkommen und die hätten vielleicht
gerne diesen deutschen Pass ich habe es
bei mir selbst erlebt als ich den
bekommen konnte ohne meinen
italienischen abzugeben ich wollte mal
nicht italienisch schon fast nicht
abgeben das hat mir was bedeutet war ein
schön
weil du müsstest doch im Zweifelsfall
müsstest du doch Italien verteidigen und
nicht Deutschland oder ich verteidige
alles was geht weißt du doch ich ich bin
bin da bin da gleich in zwei Armeen
gleichzeitig
nein aber jetzt ernsthaft noch mal das
bedeutet natürlich was das ist eine Form
von Anerkennung ja und das war ein guter
Moment ja und ich mochte das und wenn du
anfängst so darüber zu reden wir dürfen
nicht in deutschen Pass beispielsweise
verarschen was machst du denn wenn es so
wie zum Beispiel in Zentral und in
Osteuropa ja die Dinge durch
demografischen Wandel durch Abwanderung
durch die Tatsache dass man keine Kinder
mehr kriegt hast du plötzlich eine neue
artige Gesellschaft in der 20% der
arbeitenden nicht wahlberechtigt sind
weil du willst ja den passt nicht
verschenken 40% der Wahlberechtigten
haben aber weil sie zu alt sind aber
gerade darüber gesprochen die Oma den
Arbeitsmarkt schon verlassen und
vielleicht
Prozent der Wählerschaft Leben außer
Landes weil sie irgendwann mal weg sind
aber immer noch den Pass ihre Heimat
haben das führt zu ganz neuen
Gesellschaftsstrukturen und die Frage
ist bilden die die dann noch wählen
bilden die eigentlich wirklich dann
dieses Land ab sitzen dann im Parlament
die Leute die wirklich sozusagen
repräsentativ für dieses Land sind oder
was ist das dann für ein für eine
Regierung die du dann zum Beispiel hast
ja das sind alles so Fragen die sich
alle damit anschließend da werden wir
Antworten finden müssen und da kann man
glaube ich nicht so so so so ganz platt
und Blumen polemisch diskutieren das
funktioniert nicht mehr aber es ist
immer so ein schön geeignettes Thema für
problemeigen ja wenn man keine Lösung
hat ja wird mein Problem ist das ist
einfach so dann beschimpft man einfach
das bestehende oder man beschimpft die
anderen und die sind noch lange nicht in
die Phase eingetreten und wirklich
konstruktive Gedanken darüber zu machen
wie wir unsere Gesellschaft und unter
den Vorzeichen des demografischen
Handels verändern müssen und das ist
übrigens was für mich wieder be Harald
das Kippen wir den nächsten Generation
vor die Füße sollen die die große
Rentenreform machen sollen die den
Umstieg ins Grundeinkommen machen sollen
die die riesige Gesundheitsreform machen
wo wir in allen Ecken und Enden das Ding
neu aufziehen müssen und so weiter die
Generation die wir jetzt haben und die
Regierung die wir jetzt haben und ich
wette auch die künftige Regierung die
nächste die wir haben werden das nicht
angehen
wir sind gelähmt und das ist auch etwas
was
Gesellschaften sind wir sind alle wie
ein bisschen mit Gott
in jeder modernen westlichen Industrie
Gesellschafter da ist was dran wir haben
also auch unsere unsere synchronen und
unsere mentale
Rose auch ein schönes Wort oh mein Gott
Richard soweit so düster ja gut dass man
mal drüber geredet haben
über lauter kluge kluge Ideen ja wie man
das alles verbessert wird und deswegen
ging mir das vor mit den mit den Fronten
die sich da so Aufbauen ging mir das so
nahe ich glaube wir müssen das ganz ganz
anders machen wir dürfen nicht diese
Fronten aufbauen nicht die bösen Boomer
gegen die böse generationsset und so
weiter
sondern wir müssen zusammenarbeiten wir
müssen diese Boomer auch dazu bringen äh
Typen wie dich ja die jetzt demnächst
den Rente gehen dass sie noch ein
bisschen weitermacht ihr müsst noch ein
bisschen dabei bleiben ihr seid gesund
ihr seid die Pferde ich werde mich
bemühen ja du weißt was ich meine wir
brauchen so ein Generationenvertrag wir
brauchen eine gemeinsame Idee und wir
müssen uns irgendwie mögen und uns nicht
gegenseitig doof finden das bringt uns
nicht weiter das war jetzt das Wort zum
Freitag man ist alles richtig alles war
alles Weise und alles ziemlich schwierig
zu realisieren sehr schön in diesem
Sinne danke sehr Spaß gemacht gut ja
alles gut tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und
Popstars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]